[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'être avec nous
voilà on va jouer tout de suite action
pour un don c'est parti
on va s'amuser mais on va aussi donner
de l'argent pour une association dans
l'écran il y a neuf cases des cases à 50
euros 100 euros 200 euros 500 euros et
on va essayer de faire le plus de choses
possibles c'est fait voilà on va choisir
une autre case mon coeur merci et monk m
donc ça c'est bon on a gagné sans les
morceaux pour la rue cyrille il en a
garoché des serpents je vais en boîte de
nuit encore la semaine dernière
gardons bien ouais ouais bah ouais c'est
400 euros la c4
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour çà sent heureux ce sera ma
seconde on fera des comptes tous en
sorte d'accord avant gérard louvin vous
posez le crapaud sur la tête dit non
bush puis c'est très mignon sera podium
est 100 euros la passe que 50 euros
c'est ce que j'aime j'avale c'est à dire
[Applaudissements]
oui
évitez habitant et par an
voilà
pour 50 euros si on va faire très vite
le tap suisse
daniel
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait
[Musique]